if you'd wanted to know what the future
looked like before it arrived all you
really had to do was look at the Jetsons
[Music]
the television series described many
things we now see in the 21st century
long before we even finished the 20th
The Jetsons predicted our present
technology and life style so since they
were so great at telling us what today
would look like what can this cartoon
family teach us about future tech and
how automation will alter our lives you
think you think your machine is supposed
to do the thinking judging your feelings
like everyone else the future is
happening now the question is when will
it be distributed so everyone benefits
from it hey everyone I'm Joel this is
aj+ and this Sunday we're looking into a
colorful cartoon past to better
understand our automated future and yes
we will talk about robots jobs and the
dark side of automation
[Music]
flying cars moving walkways
videoconferencing computers and robotic
maids those are all things the Jetsons
had when George Jane Judy and Elroy
premiered on ABC in 1962 all those
things were unimaginable as a part of
daily life future Tech was color TV when
the Jetsons began because it wasn't
until the 1960s that color televisions
began selling and mass so the thought
that Rosie the family's robotic maid
would one day become a part of daily
life as an automatic vacuum cleaner may
have been inconceivable then but in 2018
Rosie looks like this and sounds like
this
you have 12 events scheduled the world
is rushing to automate think grocery
store checkout self-driving cars and how
shipping has evolved in fact the
automated household of the Jetsons is
only a decade away according to tech
entrepreneur Vivek Wadhwa
but when I was young it was my favorite
TV series I expect to have a robot like
Rosie cleaning up after me rather than
having servants and maids and chauffeurs
we'll have robots serving us
[Music]
so maybe your morning routine doesn't
look exactly like George Jetson yet but
it already has some similarities and
unlike the Jetsons total embrace of the
technology around them society and real
life has been hesitant about some
technological advances the trepidation
may have something to do with hearing
forecasts like this one from World Bank
president Jim Yong Kim we estimate that
two-thirds of all jobs that currently
exist in developing countries will be
wiped out by automation
take a second to think of any and every
job that makes up our economy
well 50% of those work activities are
technically able to be automated by
current technologies even the Obama
White House said that almost every
driving job that's your taxi driver the
delivery driver who delivers the food to
your local grocery store and the
long-haul truckers you see on the
interstate all of their jobs will be
automated that's up you know like
what are they gonna do if they make
everything autonomous maybe hearing
those statistics makes you want to panic
but AI and robotics expert Neil Jacobs
Dean says you don't have to and
shouldn't get hysterical about the worst
that can happen with automation if you
run your risk assessment by what's the
worst that can happen you would run a
risk assessment around many of the
technologies that are already in the
world today and conclude that they
should all be banned including cars
Jacobson says we haven't banned vehicles
just because they have the potential to
run down pedestrians that's a worst-case
scenario and he says if we use it to
determine the future of cars we would
never have had them so we have cars and
actually we have much more than you may
realize
wadhwa says it's important to recognize
just how far out emission and AI have
already come we have to understand the
technology advance is an accepted fact
that this is gonna happen
don't be denial about it understand the
fact that every industry is gonna be
impacted and when he says AI and
automation will impact every single
industry he means it it's not just jobs
reliant upon physical labor better at
risk
those are things you've probably already
heard and thought about like the truck
driver example we talked about earlier
you can also expect careers that require
a lot of intelligence to be disrupted
and here's why because what artificial
intelligence does is it analyzes data
information and makes decisions we're
going to see them augment humans and
human roles so they'll be machines plus
humans outperforming either humans or
machines alone whoa maybe this is why in
a world filled with advanced technology
George Jetsons only job is to push a
couple of buttons
after all I'm a darn good digital Windex
operator you gotta have it up here to
not have it start these things and
according to mr. Spacely he didn't even
do that well this means even George's
cushy job could be disrupted too I don't
think that there's any limit to what
these systems can learn to do eventually
Jacobson says automations benefits won't
come without turmoil aka serious growing
pains the question is not whether AI and
robotics will create new jobs because
it's absolutely true that they will
create and do create new jobs the the
question is what's the ratio of new job
creation to job displacement or
destruction and I think that ratio could
easily be unfavorable
at least in the short term to understand
what this could mean let's look at the
medical industry there are already
digital doctors that can look at your
health and digital tutors that can teach
you what WA says the ability to diagnose
yourself and have AI advise you on
maintaining your health is not far away
in fact he says there will be fewer
doctors because of this and it may
affect some of the most specialized
positions first if you're questioning
what other jobs will be available in the
automated age realize we may already be
doing them and just not getting
in the long term we could create new
jobs that are jobs that we don't see
today or people don't get paid to do
today a lot of work that people do on in
volunteer work could be paid we are
already doing many jobs in today's world
that people would never call a job you
know 200 years ago to prepare for this
future Wadhwa says the best way to deal
with automations disruption is to look
at the past take a deep breath okay but
not that far in the past and in my
interview wadhwa told me that the case
study to look at is the Great Depression
the crippling economic downturn left
about a quarter of the workforce jobless
at one point the federal government's
response is what's known as the New Deal
it included public works projects and
financial reforms all aimed at getting
people back to work so much like the
Great Depression the disruption
automation and a I bring gives us a
chance to reboot our lives we can
rethink our society we think on entire
value system and and go back to what
matters this is the opportunity we have
now all in the next 10 15 20 years while
we're thinking of all the changes needed
in the United States to deal with the
result of automation just know it's not
a one-size-fits-all solution what's
required in Nigeria Australia or India
isn't the same as the u.s. countries
such as India and Bangladesh and and
Pakistan for example this infrastructure
to be built we can put all these people
to work in building new cities abandon
the existing cities which are polluted
and filthy but there is one thing all
nations will have to troubleshoot we
really need to think ahead about what
we're going to do to help people
maintain a high quality of life
lifestyle if we're going to rely on jobs
being the primary mechanism of wealth
distribution
we might easily see businesses cutting
jobs and replacing those jobs with
automation so yes automation and AI will
bring a lot of changes a lot of which
will be very uncomfortable it's not all
hopeless you know you know who says we
have to work 40 50 60 hours a week why
our jobs so important when if we only
have to work five or 10 hours a week
what if everyone now had everything they
needed and the purpose of life the goals
that we had were to seek enlightenment
hey thanks for watching be sure to LIKE
share and subscribe and I just produced
a three-part series on this very topic
ai automation and robotics so be sure to
check that out